bobbit's Ross Tucker really appreciate
you coming on the show are they juice
them or not or the balls different or
not Bob you know you talk to pictures
they sure are [ __ ] you live all say that
because balls are flying up and I'm
looking to have over six thousand a
homerun fit this year which will shatter
every every record in baseball history
you know you're talking about the
steroid era and everything else we're
still having more hormones hit by that
guys are going off as a field just like
this throw a daisy in the bodies aren't
juice now now it's the balls they're
flying out you know the places were
we've never seen balls it so I don't
understand why this is even something
that needs to be debated like can't
somebody take a foul ball or a homerun
ball and test it and see if it's
different than the balls are used to be
or should be yeah and some places are
they know it's a difference you know
baseball says it's all within the
specifications but you know you see the
specifications were kind of a wide range
in some players say they'll pick up a
ball the hardest thing they've ever felt
and not ever these boss feels the same
the trouble is the pitcher state also
causes some blisters and broken else
problems because nobody has that seem to
grip into and you're putting a tighter
grip in the ball actually do some minor
hinges so basically it might just be a
semantics thing with Major League
Baseball because they're saying it's
within the specification but it could be
like a deflategate football thing where
maybe before it was at sixteen point
five psi and now it's at eighteen point
five psi both of which are in the
specifications but clearly a tighter
more wound ball exactly you know what
they're saying is it wasn't a cognizant
effort but yeah let's be honest I mean
baseball fans love home runs offenses
down in the game base flows concerned
and all of a sudden we're seeing those
uh you know those home runs so yeah I
think it may be a Madison minute you
know it's not like tough you know so
it's a home under the home run derby
those balls are like Super Bowls those
things
really do stuff you'll see it here in
about ten days or you know you'll get
see 500 home runs
not those aren't real baseball these are
but there's something different about
them start with Bob Nightingale there's
a really nice job covering baseball
Major League Baseball for USA Today is
there or could there possibly be any
other explanation Bob no no people look
into hey the pitch is so harder so if
you swing harder you can go further by
that's been kind of squelch set theory
and oh guys a launch and trying to
change their launch angles they hit a
home lines with this fine
you shouldn't have guys going the
opposite field you shouldn't have all
these guys in 480 490 feet homers so
yeah it's just you know we're seeing
stuff we haven't seen you know back in
the early and the early on you know mm
so why wouldn't maybe baseball just kind
of admit to it just say yeah we're
juicing them up a little bit they're a
little different than they used to be
well if you change the ball you're
supposed to go through the Union and
everything else and you know that's the
commissioner Japanese Commissioner
baseball did that without anybody
knowing about it and independent design
so you don't want to you know come out
and say hey we're changing it which
changes records everything else oh yeah
they are within specifications that's
all they're saying they're not saying
the balls exactly the same and even
pitchers will tell you you know not
every ball still the same either it's
just a lot of them now feel a whole lot
different than you have in the past
particularly without those seams
I think it's debated the study of that a
couple years ago in balls with the Holly
any seam at all but we'll go about 30
feet further so you know you mentioned
the records I guess my thing would be I
know baseball they hold their records so
dear but I guess my question is like
there's no way the balls that they're
using now are like what they were using
when Babe Ruth was playing so and I'm
sure they've changed over time so is it
really that much of a records deal
because they can't be the same ball as a
baby
Roots was using no those balls have
changed a lot over the years you know
yeah root days to the forties of change
different manufacturers so the ball has
gone through a lot of changes so I don't
think it's really going to bother
anybody this year because no one's going
to break yeah I was gonna break bonds
record no one's go going on the future
you know get over 60 or old runs no
thanks certainly another certainly not
over 70 home run if someone's on pace to
do that then I think would be a lot more
people going berserk about it just
because everybody holds baseball records
so sacred so I guess my question would
be if they're not juicing the balls why
not and I know what you said about the
Union and stuff like that but like who
gets hurt by that in other words Bob you
know I'm a former football player if the
NFL could they would juice the heck out
of the balls I mean to try you know
every every rule the NFL implement is to
increase scoring for the fans and
fantasy football and stuff I mean if
they're not using the ball for more home
runs
why not seems like a very good business
proposition no it does I mean yeah and
all those surveys have shown that fans
love the hormones all of the strikeouts
too you know it hurts pitchers obviously
your er a goes up you give up record
number of home runs
I mean Clayton Kershaw pretty give him
up more home runs in this season and he
has his entire career and we got a whole
half people left I think John Lackey is
given up more months than ever
so it hurts those guys for sure took the
younger guys who don't have a contract
and you know Scouts and team executives
say wait a minute now is this guy gone
backwards at the pitcher but it may just
be more of a more of a polishing last
question Bob there are a couple of
notable injuries last night with Fowler
and Turner notable for different reasons
but just curious to get your thoughts on
on the significance of both those
injuries
yeah I mean the Nationals standpoint I
think they'll stay within and you come
upon a minor league any default just
because that's such a big lead but even
y'all have when their people say man
whose ball so so hard now you know we're
not saying that you would have got hurt
but we're seeing more bruises and more
broken balls or some of these baseball's
as well and yeah a real real shame would
be with the Yankees in Fowler I'm going
to kid just gets called up he's gonna
have his parents meet him in Houston
everything to having that bat get to
play the field and that's it
and now young he's out for six months if
you know just you know who knows whether
we'll ever see him again the major
leagues
so yeah just a heartbreaking injury
particularly for him yeah we'll see
Turner back
you don't know where we could see if our
back Bob really appreciate the time
interesting story I really liked all the
quotes from both pitchers and hitters
and coaches that was well done thank you
so much about the trip today all right
there he is Bob nightingale from USA
Today the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience